analyse avec françois jonsi général de
brigade expert en géostratégie première
question cette décision de la france
décision militaire ou politique
je pense que c'est une réponse double la
première la plus simple et militaires
aujourd'hui nous avons mille hommes en
irak qui forment l'armée irakienne il en
a formé japy de 13000 c'est quand même
pas anodin et nous sommes face à un
risque de retrait potentiel des
américains qui sont importants dans la
zone donc la question militaire c'est
comment compenser un départ éventuel des
américains dans la zone irakienne et
donc rester efficace ça c'est l'aspect
militaire
l'aspect politique c'est aussi un
message vers pas le moyen-orient mais
sans doute l'europe et sinon les états
unis pour dire nous avons une force
aéronavale
cette force aéronavale d'abord
comprendra plusieurs navires de l'union
européenne nous sommes bien dans une
logique europe de la défense en quelque
sorte et nous mettons tout le monde
ensemble pour dire 'oui nous européens
on va dans cette région du monde en
force militaire organisé assuré le
combat contre dèche
le groupe aéronaval 1 viendra soutenir
cette opération en irak seulement de
janvier à avril est ce que c'est un
délai qui vous paraît
suffisant je dirai au départ que ses
dents vu deux porte-avions le premier se
serait pas posée on en a car on fait
avec
ensuite il faut jamais oublier que les
forces militaires ont besoin de
récupérer
nous avons un groupe aéronaval et a le
besoin
au bout de quatre mois d'opération de se
remettre en condition ce qui est tout à
fait valable pour toutes les opérations
dont qui a rien d'extraordinaire à ce
que cette opération dure que quatre mois
non pas pour des raisons militaires
mais pour des raisons de conditions
militaires ont pas user les personnels
trop vite
ensuite il me semble bien qu'une autre
mission est prévue plus vers le nord de
l'europe avec ce groupe euronaval mais
ya pas eu beaucoup de détails qui sont
sortis sur la question puisque ça doit
se déployer justement après l'irak en
atlantique du nord mais pour l'instant
pas plus de précisions alors le porte
avions sera le coeur d' opération
combinée de plusieurs pays européens à
ce monde de la france
une europe de la défense peut-elle se
former au sein de l'otan alors je pense
que lier les deux mots vous avez évoqué
autant et europe de la défense
il est certain que tous les états
européens aujourd'hui par l'otan est pas
vraiment l'europe de la défense
ensuite je crois que le message
politique suite à la question de déposer
ya quelques instants est aussi très fort
c'est emmanuel mâcon a dit à quelques
semaines que l'otan est en mort
cérébrale
que fait-il il rassemble des forces
européennes sous une forme sous un
format militaire pour agir et non pas
uniquement parler alors europe de la
défense ou autant je ne fais pas le
choix dit simplement l'europe parle avec
ses forces armées dans une situation
opérationnelle précise et des états
européens veulent travailler ensemble
militairement parlant c'est ça le
message je crois qu'il faut comprendre
justement comment jugez vous la position
de l'otan il rappelle quelques temps qui
a dit qu'elle allait retirer quelques
hommes de l'est de l'irak parce que la
situation semblait un peu compromise ne
faut jamais oublier que l'otan est une
alliance dans laquelle chaque état reste
souverain en fait ce sont des décisions
nationales et ont eu lieu je crois que
si les allemands il ya une autre nation
je me rappelle plus qui a retiré ses
forces au canada voilà qui est pour des
forces
pour des raisons de sécurité mais c'est
une décision nationale l'otan ne fait
que selon lui donne donc si des états
dit je m'en vais ben ils s'en vont et
puis le temps on fait avec
donc il ne faut pas préjuger de ce que
je pense pas que ce soit l'otan qui soit
concerné dans cette affaire là mes
dépositions de souveraineté nationale et
de choix politiques intérieurs de
certains états et quelle efficacité de
l'otan alors dans ce cas là l'otan là on
va sortir peut-être un peu de notre
sujet mais l'otan c'est quoi c'est une
alliance où on apprend à travailler
ensemble avec les mêmes procédures en
étant capable de planifier des
opérations dans les états majors en
donnant des forces
voilà donc d'un côté de défaut peut
prêter à planifier les opérations donc
le temps c'est ça c'est assurer une
cohérence de la défense commune
maintenant sur le terrain on ne pouvait
pas retirer les intérêts nationaux et
certains pays ne l'ont jamais perdre des
soldats à bagdad donc on peut le
comprendre
très rapidement on va parler de la
conférence de presse de sergueï lavrov
qui l'a tenue à quelques instants
justement il a parlé de la position de
la russie par rapport aux confits trop
nombreux qui est en ce moment et sur le
conflit vit bien on voit bien qu ce
moment la russie 20 peut jouer le rôle
de médiateur il y aura une conférence
internationale ce dimanche à berlin mais
également une réunion à moscou il ya
quelques jours comment jugez-vous
justement le rôle de la russie dans ce
conflit libyen on est dans une situation
où la turquie et la russie jeudi me bien
les deux sont tous les deux concernés
veulent avoir un rôle plus important
dans la gestion des crises
internationales notamment entre le
moyen-orient et l'afrique du nord
c'est le premier point donc chacun
pousse ses pions de telle façon que ils
puissent être partie prenante
statuant quand même que ce soit des
européens se soient loués nus personne
aujourd'hui n'arrive à trouver une
décision à obtenir une décision sur le
terrain et nous avons aussi peut-être un
troisième point des enjeux qui sont
peut-être pas uniquement politiques qui
sont peut-être aussi
économique par l'accès au gaz au pétrole
est contenu ce qui se passe de la
turquie avec la turquie au large de
chypre de la russie vis-à-vis de
l'europe et de l'allemagne avec des
exportations
vous avez un contexte je dirais gaziers
pétroliers qui fait que la libye est un
sujet intéressant pour que des états qui
n'étaient pas présents jusqu'à présent
viennent s'immiscer dans cet
affrontement
on trouve des relais français de parts
et d'autres où on retrouve l'onu qui
soutient sa rage donc est ce nombre de
phénomènes où il ya une opportunité pour
ces états qui jouent leur carte de
relations internationales et de
politique étrangère général merci
d'avoir été avec nous sur rt france mars